taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking what's up taste
buddies it's the
taste buds podcast the
taste buds podcast
the second verse i don't think no no
well it's not doesn't play in the song
does it
i don't know tim you fade out usually
right yeah we cut it after the first
verse
yeah okay okay okay so it goes uh yeah
if you uh
taste buzz taste buds if you don't want
your check
no if you don't watch your boots they'll
take your pictures about your boots get
your boots laced up i know it i know i
know
uh i'm forgetting the pay stubs line if
you don't want your purse they'll take
your pay stubs
that's right yes better better put on
your boots make sure they're laced up
that's right
that's it babe and speaking of hip hop
yeah
i just was what i was doing in reference
in reference to a lot of dms i've been
getting okay about various things taking
place
around the internet that may or may not
sort of be reminiscent of what we do
here on this show oh i don't know
uh yeah so while we're on the subject of
hip-hop i'm gonna quote
the rizza from the intro to side two
disc one oh of wu tang forever
right before triumph kicks in you know
what everybody
it's all right to show love to a dude
but stop biting my
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm the osiris of this [ __ ] taste buds
has been here forever
we bomb atomically all right
yeah a six pack of frosted dota to the
streetcar they designed
we're just two guys trying to make our
way
i know what are you gonna do we're
getting knocked around by uh
the food network the food network was
insane
that was insane i mean it's just too
coincidental that they put peanut butter
and jelly against grilled cheese peanut
butter jelly versus grilled cheese
two weeks after our episode i know it
was
nuts i know that was nuts you gotta
just there's so many foods and like why
would you take this they're seeing the
comments because
networks like that they have they have a
social media person that responds to
people
they're seeing the comments saying guys
this podcast already did this they're
seeing it and they're just ignoring it
but yeah
it was right after which is weird but
hey just let's just let's just take this
to the on the road and do a do a food
network show
here we go yeah we we're up for hire
mijo and pimper for hire
yeah food network yeah who knows move
this [ __ ] out of my house
[Laughter]
uh oh so wait the other thing we're
gonna talk about this this is i
also thought that this was a bite but it
wasn't a bite oh i love the word bite
yeah sweat sweating us biting us yeah
sweating oh [ __ ]
uh there's a new candy bar out now we've
talked
on the show about the greatest candy bar
of all time being the whatchamacallit
watching my caller hands down which by
the way i watched old vintage uh watch
mccall commercials on youtube the other
night yeah
god damn it has decreased in size in a
way that like
oh it's outrageous um
it's a shame it was so big when it first
came out that when the kid's eating it
in the commercial
you can just even when they're not
intending for you to you can see the
inside of it you can see what's going on
in there
that's what that's how much of a of a
cross surface area
yeah yeah yeah it was like it was bigger
than a concurrent king size
uh just go with it yeah sure i guess so
well i've never seen a king-sized
watchmaker so i was trying to
they stopped calling them king-sized too
i think they call them like
like uh shareable so now or something
they
they
remarketed that too uh so there's
by the way milky way fudge just to
digress for a second
milky way fudge just came out and they
have a double
i followed these snack guys on youtube i
think it's called mike's kitchen
but they have these two dudes just they
just sit in this kitchen they just eat
snacks and they just tell you if they're
good or not oh my god um
uh michael ian black and um i'm
forgetting his name mike and uh
eat snacks it was it was a podcast
that's not what this is
okay this is pimp real quick tom mike
i'm digressing all over the place so i'm
gonna get back to the whatchamacallit
go back just put in mike's kitchen uh
youtube and see what comes up
i i want to give these guys a shout out
nah that's not it
that's mike's kitchen on youtube yeah i
know so it's i'm wrong it's not mike's
kitchen
uh something
[Music]
uh snacks gonna search the whole
internet with that board of a terminal
snacks kitchen youtube
oh yeah who's gonna come with us
yeah all right anyway there is these
guys i gotta find them again
uh but i want to give them a shout out
on one of the episodes but anyway
all they do is they go they go to five
below
uh i think dollar tree
and walmart and they just buy snacks at
all three
and then they eat them on camera in
their kitchen and they just tell you if
they're good or not
that's the show that's the show i love
the show but anyway they got a milky way
fudge which is a new milky way
okay and the guy made a point to say
when he
when he took it out he goes look at that
he goes that's almost the size of a real
candy bar
and i was like what do you mean almost
the size of a real and then he goes
there's two of these in here and i was
like oh wow milky way fudge bringing
bring in some sides this is how they do
it now right because they just read pim
pulled up
that as of like 2013 or something they
said
king-sized candy will no longer be made
after 2013 says maker of eminem's twix
and snickers
king-sized candy bars will give way to
products with no more than 250 calories
that's from 2012. that's a crock of [ __ ]
because what they do now is they put two
smaller ones in there
and say serving sizes too but the
but these were big i watched them eat
them really they weren't small that's
what i'm saying
i felt like milky way kind of delivered
with some
length and girth i can't believe i can't
believe what you're about to tell me
right now okay so a sequel candy bar
has been released we have to get this to
the what you're gonna call it
it's called the whoosie what's it
what now what a name here's the thing
the only possible next name
bring up the cover excuse me the picture
of the kitty i need a big picture of
that candy bar because there's a couple
things
i got to draw attention to on that
rapper
okay so i'm in the writing it might be
fun
oh man that's up there that that's right
away with what you're gonna call it
right
now i'm in a rite aid one day i see
these things right i go
who's he what's it that sounds like what
you'll call it there is nothing on the
front label of this wrapper to tell you
who manufactures it
so i'm going what is this then it says
underneath the name comedy bar named by
lisa
m and i seriously started getting hot
inside the rite aid and i'm going
who does who is this lisa m broad
acting like she came up with an original
candy bar here
called a who's he what's it this is such
a bite off of the water
call it well then i find out i finally
google it i
see for three weeks about this and then
i finally google it and i find out who's
he what's it
is in fact a sequel bar to the k to the
whatchamacallit made by the same candy
company
and the reason her name is on the front
is because they crowd sourced the name
it was a contest to see who won it and
if you if you named it and they picked
you they put your name on the thing
she didn't guess what they were going to
call it no she gave them the name
yeah it's the name of the wrestler is in
the vernacular isn't it like a
whatchamacallit
and a who's he what's it like that's the
first time i heard the phrase who's he
wants it
it isn't i don't think so i never heard
that phrase
no that says no
i've heard that is it possible the first
time i heard it was
when did this come out pimp like a
couple months ago
no but i you've heard of i've heard of
wait was whatchamacallit a thing
before the bar was called what should i
call it yeah because you go it's a
what's your
caller what you're gonna call it that
you know i was down at the
whatchamacallit the uh
yeah and i've heard people in the same
vein go uh who's what's it not that they
do it it might have been like old-timey
speak but like
i don't think koozie watts is a thing i
think you're concocting the whole
universe of something
what should i call it what should i call
it is in the dictionary
yeah used to re informal noun used to
refer to a person or thing
whose name one cannot recall does not
know or does not wish to specify
she wanted me to get the watchmakola
from her bureau yeah
i wonder what i wonder what she was
talking about in that situation yeah
but that was that was the old commercial
is that what they're calling it now
the commercial with the kids that i
watched was like it was like it was like
a
i didn't watch the commercial with kids
there were kids
there were kids in the commercial
it's you and like like a handful of
six-year-olds
but no the the the in the commercial
that's was the whole gag was it was like
a who's on first the kid's like what's
that candy bar and he's like
i remember that it's a whatchamacallit
he's like what are you calling it what's
it called yeah yeah
yeah but wait wait wait wait can you see
if he wants it is in the ditch
i don't think it is babe i think i think
that that's this is a new thing
this is a new like that's why they had
to have a contest because they were like
there's no other word
oh man she came up with the who's he
what's it i've never heard that before
you guys you guys got a sound off in the
comments
and i don't know if i've ever said that
before but but am i crazy list
you guys listening like have you ever
heard the phrase who's he what's it
before
this chocolate bar came out a few months
ago who is this lisa m
i'm telling you i thought it was a lady
that just made up a new candy bar on her
i thought it was an indie rogue candy
bar that this lady made up that copied
what you're gonna call it
but it's not it's it's actually what is
different it says chocolate
chocolate chocolate crisps and peanut
butter
it's i think what is different i think
it's a chocolaty version
i think it's like the sister version of
the like a sister bar to the
whatchamacallit
but it's like it's a chocolatey version
of the whatchamacallit oh is it
chocolatey
because they inside of the
whatchamacallit there's no chocolate to
be found it's
all correct so i didn't see they said
there was chocolate in it though
forty three thousand entries she won
five
years ago a year supply of hoosier
watson bars and five thousand in cash
well let me just start to say something
here
february 2021 you're right two months
old okay first of all
is it this is the mars is it hershey
that hershey got away
with they could have hired their they
probably have an in-house marketing i
mean like
i would imagine a firm couldn't come up
with a who's what they they got away
with their new brand
name for five grand five grand five
grand
they own it forever it's oh i see it's
chocolate in the middle
it's delicious i i mean we need to get
one of these
stat it looks delicious dude i like the
way they even you could tell it's in the
same family though you can't tell by the
font and the writing
it's the same thing it's just it's just
a chocolate crisp version
of this version it's gonna be fine but
i'm telling you right now
the whatchamacallit is perfect so i
don't know dude that
i feel in recent years the
whatchamacallit has been a little
lacking in flavor
yeah and i feel like that the extra
chocolate crispies might take this thing
over the fence
because that you know what that looks
like it tastes like to me those
chocolate eclair
ice cream bars the the good humor ones
yeah the chocolate bits on the outside
that's what that looks like to me all
right and those things are i mean is
there anything more
they jus right chocolate eclair it's
okay there's the ice cream barring me
yeah i still i go that's like my third
i go toasted almond you get then i drop
it like it's cold with a strawberry
short
strawberry hold on i need you to shush
pimp
write that down the fact that you that's
an episode
oh it is a classic good humor barbara's
bar that's an episode
yeah that could be an episode toasted
let's leave it let's just leave it
yeah toasted yeah yeah oh yeah the
eclair is my
least favorite in that grouping i want
you to leave it alone right now
we're gonna come back to it whoa look at
that that's new stuff
reese's the good humor toasted almond
babe
good humor pop tart brown sugar cinnamon
all right gross
we're all over the charts here one thing
though is that lisa m also gets her
her name on the packaging i wonder for
how long that lasts and her whole name
is
just for the roll out yeah you don't
know who it is so there's lisa sounds
like frontend
yeah in at least em east lee sam says
like a freestyle
uh club artist from the early 90s
[Laughter]
yeah at least i'm from queens yeah
please don't go away from
i think that's a regional um genre
freestyle music like tka
stevie b yeah you know
little susie lisa m if you watch this
show but any chance reach out to us we'd
love to talk to you oh
lisa m we have you on as a guest we eat
lucy watch this all day long
i would love to talk to lisa m we would
love to do the who's he what's it on the
show while we're talking to her
oh man i can't wait i'm gonna i'm gonna
go for a whoosie what's it today
i'm gonna go to my local grocer you
don't want to wait to see if we can get
in touch with lisa m and eat it with her
for the first time
all right odds of her fine we'll go get
a who's he watching after yeah but we
could still
we could still eat it with her freestyle
music is a form of hip-hop
dance is that how you describe freestyle
music i would say
hip-hop dance i would never describe it
that way latin hip-hop or latin pop i
would describe it as
more latin pop that originated from the
electro funk of africa bambada and the
soul
sonic forces 1982 seminal track planet
rock
oh wow they're pinpointing that the
genre of freestyle music
was birthed from a singular song
wow latin percussion heavy syncopation
of things i mean they all
sound very similar but they were
in the tri-state area here on the east
coast in like the
like like what do you want to call it
late 80s early 90s it was big here but
it also too
it's huge on the west coast too because
you had egyptian lover on the west coast
and
you know what i mean like egyptian lover
yeah you never listen to egyptian lovers
no but
he's awesome oh i know the name of the
song no no he was a he was a musician
he is a musician yeah i didn't know that
you would love egyptian lover
and then if you listen to the early dr
dre stuff it's all that kind of stuff
it's all like you know yeah so they're
saying frieza it did it just died one
day
it was like you know when you like have
a like a like a like a pair of clothes
or
something hanging in the house that you
like stylistically then all of a sudden
one day you're like
i wore this or like like it's like
you're still hanging or it's still you
still wear it
and you like transition out of that as
your aesthetic and you're like
what was i doing for all these years i
think that's what happened collectively
with freestyle music
everyone's like alright we've kind of
had enough of this are we still
listening to this i still like i still
like some of it
i like the stuff like the egyptian lover
stuff in the africa bambada stuff that's
a little more like
robot vocoder voice over that's the
stuff i still like these are very mellow
the stuff with the singing and stuff i'm
not as into
but you know who loves it is that guy
tommy um
well i'm also a huge fan of on instagram
tommy from uh
car guys or car dudes whatever the show
it's called
what's that show google tommy car see
what comes up
tommy wait wait go down tommy is that
him no that's not him
tommy uh the wait uh pimp
i i could tell you how to find it google
tommy
take it east e-a-s-e and it'll come
right up yeah
yeah big time tommy there he is
this guy's awesome
oh my god he's very extra
every video is playing freestyle music
and he says that's the old school way
take it ease take it easy he's the best
dude i love this one take it easy
that's you've heard take it east right
uh i don't know if i ever heard it until
tommy
really time tommy oh i've heard it but
then again i i'm from staten island
i love this guy yeah i think this guy
he's either jersey or staten island but
so so she gets her name on the package
for a certain amount of time she gets
five grand
and she gets what do you think a year's
worth of watching my qualities one a day
she'd be dead by 2021 right
nothing against what nothing something
tells me these things will keep
if you don't eat them right away no but
i mean what what do you think they
consider it's not one a week
that's different no it's probably one a
day for a year so you got 365 bucks
bars yeah what happens if you who's you
what's in a day for a year
nothing nothing what happened i already
do it
in other forms right what do you yeah i
mean people eat ice cream every single
night you want to do the who's he watson
challenge no i do not
no i do watch it every day of the year
no i do not account
for the calendar i'll do the hoagie
challenge i'll eat hoagie every day for
a year
no you can't do that you think i can't
do it
right now i know that you can't do that
why because you're not
understanding what that means you're
gonna have a hoagie 365 days
in a row yeah how much i believe in the
house you would transform
yourself i mean
i i want to give you a chance to back to
to beat beep beep back
out of this wait what because you're
throwing down a gauntlet right now i
don't think you want to get into plus
there's no way to verify
although there is i would need video of
you eating a hoagie every day wait in
what way
365 day super cut of you eating a hoagie
only on the patreon and that'll be a big
payoff that's like a 200 volunteer
and which wait a minute and then we'll
reveal what you look like
which way we'll put you at a blur for
365 days and then we'll reveal you
i bet you you could do it as long as you
were smart about the other meals
i know but that's the thing you can't be
that smart about the other meals
that much like it'll the hoagie will
consume your life
you'll be making plans around the hoagie
[Laughter]
you know what i mean oh i gotta have my
hoagie today i didn't have my hog yet
what's gonna be on my hoagie i can't eat
that i already had the hoagie
like and a hoagie is a hoagie like a
hoagie is a big piece of
food so you know you're gonna be
sacrificing lunches and breakfast
all over the place i would see dinner
and breakfast i'd shove it to dinner
most of the
or most days okay so what are you saying
you're saying that i'm saying i started
saying that breakfast and lunch will be
will be uh unaffected
i'm saying i'm saying i start the day
right with
with some hydration some water some
healthy fruit in the morning
maybe a salad for lunch and then three
after i do my day
days of the year i do a hoagie dinner
first of all you can't do that you can't
do
something you can't just hydrate and eat
berries
for a year so you can have hoagie
dinners and then also
you're sacrificing a year's worth of
other real dinner foods
now what are you going to do you're
going to shift your fried chicken to
lunch
but here's the thing you would be you're
you're you would be bad
you're undercutting sodium like you're
undercutting a hoagie you could do a
cheese hoagie one day
you could do a tuna hoagie one day you
could do a roast beef hoagie one day
you could do a low sodium ham okay this
is what i'm saying like you're you're
looking at this
you're looking at this is straight up
prosciutto salami hoagies every day no
not anything you want on bread you could
do
there's low sodium ops yeah but you're
going to just low sodium options for uh
for for for a few solstices no i'm
saying
i'm saying you do it you you you work in
a few low sodes
and then you do regular sodiums too
so you distill that out to medium sodium
is that that crazy i don't know if you
should be eating processed meats
for hundreds of days in a row but people
eat lunch meat every day for lunch
people at large right
but not people like it's gonna have to
get in front of canada
is that insane to sustain the
sustainability of eating a hoagie every
day for a year
i mean we'll make it interesting you
want to do something where we see if
like the listeners want to like uh
put in a money pot okay how about this
i'm making this up i don't even know if
it's legal
okay there's a part that they contribute
to once we start the patreon
or maybe not we'll do an independent an
independent auditor from coopers and
whatever
right we got one bank account where
people bet
that you'll do it and one bank account
or like
not like an account like like an escrow
account
where people bank that you don't do it
and then
the second you lose or win everybody
in the other bucket gets the cash payout
divided by the amount of contributors
did i just do something real or is that
like insane what i just said
wait what do i get you i thought that
money would be for me if i did it
yeah but you just you said you would do
this before
i even mentioned this i know you're
you're given a pretty strong argument as
to why i shouldn't do it yeah
so and now you're talking about raising
money and giving it to people that have
nothing to do with it okay
okay okay okay yeah if you if you lose
you need a motivator so if you lose you
get nothing
good day sir if you win you get
25 of the pot no i didn't see more fifty
percent of the pot
yeah but then the people put the pot
with the listeners 50 to you 50 down
i mean then how do you do it with
different con here's the problem with th
that plan
you have to you're a video of you eating
a hoagie every day
that i get there's going to be terrible
things that happen and you're going to
be like why is this motherf
posting them eating a hoagie when
there's goddamn missiles flying or
something like that you still got to do
it
but here you could just put a little
people contributing different amount of
challenges to hoagie challenge and then
they'll understand
you're gonna have people contributing
different amounts of money so if a guy
throws in a hundred bucks versus a guy
that throws in five he's gonna want a
different payout that's okay
it's it's a ten dollar entry across the
board
so all things are equal ten dollars i
think we update that one i think we
updated it it's gonna be a million
dollars in the part that you're not
going to do
but that would be good for you because
then as you do it you'll win 500 000 i
think we upped that entry
i think i think it's 20. i think you buy
in at 20.
period i think there's a rate for a
year-long bet
it's 20. that's insane
okay so it's 20 bucks
it's a long-term bet except what if you
make it like
see this is the thing what would be the
what would be the point at which you've
gone so far
that you're suffering but refuse to give
up because you've already done the
damage of like
is it like six months like you would you
bail you wouldn't be on the 11th month
i don't think you'd be on the 10th month
i don't think you bailed the night month
so if we're trying to do like vegas odds
for these people
you feel like you're in the clear after
you make what maybe the eighth month
mark or do you think you could go eight
months of a hoagie every single goddamn
day and then
stop i'm telling you this will really
make my year if you
if we if we pull this together what can
i do to help you
you can let me think about it okay maybe
you know no will do you know what we'll
do
we'll we'll make a a you could just
upload it to
no presh we'll make it like a de rosa
hoagie challenge day one day two day
three
and we'll put up every single this way
it's not a tweet it lives on the network
so people
can find it more and get involved more
maybe there's a sliding scale
because you got to get you can't just
bet 20 whenever you got to bet 20 before
it begins
but what if you're six months in would
it be ten dollars to enter at that point
no you can't
i gotta talk to a bookmaker maybe we're
gonna beat them but we'll talk about
them
all right they wanna sponsor us maybe
they'll sponsor joe's wait wait so
okay i know we have to get to today's
battle yeah
usually companies define a year's supply
based on the assumption of regular daily
or weekly consumption of a product for
instance
a year's supply of ben and jerry's is
defined as 52 pints
bastards but a starbucks k-cup giveaway
a year's supply is defined as 52
10 count packages all right i'm still
thinking they're going to give a 365 but
lisa moore if anyone knows lisa m
anyone knows her le con we want to know
how long a year supply was
it's got to be one a day i mean come on
she named the thing
do you want me to do this should you be
it should be a six month hoagie
challenge
i'm also like i'm just i don't because i
also want to make it within reach so
it's interesting
i think six months is probably a more
doable thing
well it definitely is it's 50 less time
it's not probably a more doable thing
right but probability is holy on your
side i think it's attainable
i think it's attainable tell me what you
think is attainable
and we'll go from there all right i'm
gonna have to go off when i when we go
off air i'm gonna have to put put some
thoughts you're gonna do like some
calculations yeah
so next episode we'll come back with a
potential challenge
next episode we're recording the next
episode five minutes after this one
finishes
right i need give me a couple days the
magic
give me a couple days to go think about
it oh okay yeah that's all
all right well i guess this is gonna be
a teaser it's a that's what i'm saying
this is this is something we're talking
about we you know look we've given a
pretty nice tease here
it was born speaking of which though we
try to bank episodes in case we can't
get together and whatnot it was the
pandemic goes all that stuff
but now we actually are up to speed yeah
so like
this oh are we we are right so this
episode
is coming out in a few days okay yeah so
we're kind of up to that point
we're seeing this the monday after the
saturday we recorded it
and then the episode the following
monday
we will have recorded also today and
then
we're gonna have to recognize more
episodes keep guessing based on yeah
socks and beards okay yeah we're going
french fries versus onion rings today
yeah uh that's the battle
i mean look these are all time uh
great sides for your burgers for your
hoagies
for your cheesesteaks for your chicken
parmies
you know what i mean when you go to a
start that has sandwiches these are
usually the two choices
and one of them isn't always on the menu
but
they are so commonly associated as the
side with a burger
that even burger king and a handful of
other fast food restaurants offer onion
rings
as also a choice i think arby's might
have them uh
i think carl's jr has them now look we
also know going into this
we were like we all we also agree that
tater tots
is probably the best fried potato side
to me there's nothing better than a
tater tot it's a hash brown patty in
bite-size form
it's amazing it's so good it doesn't
even need dipping sauce like i won't
when i dip tater tots and ketchup i like
it less
yeah i get what you mean you know i just
it's so
good on its own man it's just so good
and of course uh
it's founded by f neffy grigg oh okay
and golden greg what names must be from
like
portland yeah leftover slivers of cut up
potatoes
well you found it boys girls gals f
neffy
tater tots are born in 1953.
that's wild okay but so we're not
including tater tots in the debate
here's the thing french fries
french fries if we can name five
powerhouse foods
of all time you're up there with your
pizza your
french fries are up there so we know oh
wait what a formidable opponent
french fries are we know they're a heavy
heavy favorite
but we said what can we put up against
fries and there was debate
as to whether fries should just go up
against another powerhouse
food or should stay we should try to
give them opponent that's in their lane
and because onion rings
are so amazing we said why don't we take
a flyer maybe they have a punch
a puncher's chance against a french fry
i think that i i would disagree with the
powerhouse comment about french fries
really
well here's why they're like the number
one by far
besides i would say their powerhouse
okay i don't i think it's unfair to put
them on the same list as pizza
or something you would eat as a meal
usually french fries are not eating it
i mean maybe some poutine up in canada
but you know
uh but you know most of the time you're
not getting fries as your meal
it's not like you're i gotta be honest
dude i bet you if if we did something
like a civil war
like fries versus cheeseburger or
something like that
or like or even if you say effort fries
versus pizza i feel like
fries are one of the all-time powerhouse
foods
they're a powerhouse food they're just
not an entree food
they're i think they can beat an entree
they're a pick at the table food
yeah but how many times have you ordered
i mean i know there's people out there
are going to disagree with me heartily
how many times you actually ordered the
basket of fries with nothing else
you know it's more like younger at a
diner drunk food that kind of thing or
if i'm not that hungry
or if they bring over a basket for the
table but no i'm not
that's what i'm saying yeah i know that
but but no but no one's arguing the
merits of
where it belongs on the table uh what
course
it's just it's just the merits of how
addicting they are and how much people
love them and
in that instance i think you put them up
against any other powerhouse food i
think they're going to be
any food that's not another powerhouse i
think you've got to have your what is it
the axis powers
thank you yeah i really feel
yeah i just feel like they're an axis
power the front uh i mean
yeah i mean you're drifting a little
back into m m's or candy bars territory
right now but
i i i hear that all i'm saying is i'm
not gonna pick all i'm saying is like
i'm judging them as strictly as a food
as a bite as as a food
not as what box they check in the in the
in coursing them out or aside
is it they're going to go and get people
i mean
i'm just saying like i don't know what
would ever beat them so i'm wondering
at the end of this that fry's ever come
back and we just do something like
insane like that and just growing up
against something as big right
so obviously sal is team fries no i was
actually just
no that was like really that was a
really really for me like
non-partisan viewpoint yeah i'll take
fries
i'm gonna take fries no i know you're
taking fresh yeah because
downstairs you you were like let's do uh
you walked by me like cool hand luke
downstairs yeah you you did and and i
and i left you go what are you laughing
i'm like oh man just that you just
you're really you're really confident it
was like no it wasn't no not that you're
not gonna win i'm just saying it was
like i really liked it you were like
let's do uh fries there's onion rings
i'll take onion rings and then you you
slapped me twice on the shoulder and
kept walking
i i was like oh okay
i i i didn't no i did not mean for that
level of confidence i don't i don't
really that was an accident
i know folks you know that we love
cereal here at the taste buds podcast
it's no secret we talk about it all the
time and it is also no secret
that one of our favorite cereal
providers are the wonderful folks over
at magic spoon
that's part of your day breakfast most
important meal of the day
breakfast one of the most things one of
the most beautiful things about being a
kid
breakfast cereal saturday morning
cartoons
oh yeah sitting there with the box of
the fun stuff to eat
why was it fun because it was delicious
it had colors popping out of the bowl
you're watching your favorite shows it's
an experience it's a ritual it's
something you hang on to
but you get older you gotta cut down a
little bit you are selling me on this
i mean it's a it's a great product it's
a great product i eat cereal sometimes
for any meal
yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't have
to just be breakfast that's what i'm
talking about i came back around
that's what i'm talking about this is
the point now though because you're
coming back around you're eating
cereal now you need it to be a little
bit healthier yeah especially if you're
doing it every meal magic spoon zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
that's insane
only four net carbs in each serving only
140 calories
keto friendly gluten free grain free soy
free low carb gmo free
build your own box make custom boxes
flavors of cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
cinnamon
uh i mean it is they're good flavors and
your own bundle
yeah you can make your own bundle which
i like yeah i like that you can pick a
bunch of stuff that you want
and they'll send you a bunch of boxes of
it that's how it works right
yeah i mean that's that's that's
basically how the
trade a fair trade market works you
order it and pay them and you will get
goods
received and that's the magic spoon
guarantee
but you can't get yourself a deal so go
to magicspoon.com
taste buds and grab a custom bundle of
cereal
try it today trust me you're going to
use the promo code when you get there
taste buds that's your promo code code
you're gonna check out and save five
bucks with your order
magicspoon.com tastebuds and then
use the promo code tastebuds to save
five bucks
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
what is honey you guys know about honey
yet honey is an
app we all shop online we've seen that
promo code
that is so funny right we've seen the
promo code taunt us at checkout
do you know that when i shop online
which is often and there's a promo code
it says apply discount code i abandon
the cart
and i go on a search yeah for promo
codes all the time because it's telling
me that they exist and
every single time i get the same exact
websites and they all give me codes that
are expired
and do not work i agree with that now
with honey and what really bothers me
about the taunting of the
it is funny that they phrase it that way
because it does feel like a taunt
because it feels like the story you're
buying or the company that you're buying
your product from
is letting you know we could give you a
discount
if only you could figure out the codes
it's very insulting
it makes me angry uh you are not getting
the best deal right now
just so you know if that box is empty so
we love that honey supports over 30
000 stores online they range from all
kinds of sites that you know tech
products gaming products which i'm
excited about uh to popular fashion
brands even
food delivery imagine you're shopping at
one of your favorite sites and when you
check out the honey button just drops
down
and all you got to do is click apply
coupons it's not like you have to go to
the honey site
and find the code or whatever the button
just gets installed in your browser you
click it it adds the coupons
automatically it may be the biggest
no-brainer of all the ads we have it's
like yeah you just
it's there and then you just save the
money yeah takes a few seconds for them
to search but they're going to apply
what they find for you
and uh you know look i i can't tell you
how many times i've gotten free shipping
out of honey and it's just it's i mean
or you know through using honey i should
say
but uh that's huge that's huge because
sometimes you know look folks
i buy on a budget i'm not going to lie
to you i'm a thrifty kind of guy i'm
i'm a window shopper i price compare
okay
it's the only way to be sometimes when
you buy
maybe a few things you want to treat
yourself maybe a few blu-rays you'd had
your eye on that you don't necessarily
need but you want
you justify it somebody sometimes by
going okay
there's the total 60 and 23 still buying
blue race
yeah i buy blue race i like to own my
media okay
but you're looking at that totally go 60
23 i can live with that i can live with
that because i just found sixty dollars
under the couch that i didn't know it
was there
and then you go to checkout and you get
hit with that shipping
and it's a whole different place oh
shipping tax
honey babe that's what you need if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on free savings
it's literally free and installs in a
few seconds
by getting you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this podcast
uh i'd never recommend something i
didn't use that's true i i
downloaded honey the first time we got
it i've been using it ever since get
honey for free
at joinhoney.com taste buds that's
join honey dot com slash taste buds
i will say i do have a certain security
in picking onion rings because
onion rings to me in theory could be the
kitkat of this pole
it could be the thing that we had no
idea was gonna sweep and it did
uh onion rings i'll say this when
they're right
they're amazing and when they're uh when
it's an
option to have them i always choose them
almost always over fries i have fries
that i love
i have fries that i worship mcdonald's
fries i've gone on and on and on about
them on this show
to me they're one of the best things
i've ever tasted she just keeps on
what's up on and on yeah isn't that paul
davis
i don't know that's something hot rock
right there i know the song i don't know
what it's called i didn't mean to stop
you please that's okay
but when i'm just in a regular old diner
and i love a regular old diner don't get
me wrong
most of the time i will if given the
option i will take
onion rings over the french fries i find
quite
often man when french fries suck
dude they suck they do i hate those big
dry steak ones
yeah when they're not done the right way
it just feels like you're eating chunks
of dried potato
and a lot of times diners default fry is
a steak fry
right right uh but then you can't
discount the 100 of the fry
options but i'll let you continue i also
choose onion rings when they're
available over fries and i'm still
really in with the fan fries
all right well i mean look both have
great variety
both have great variety where you're
where it's not even a cheat where do you
see these
rings have a great variety yeah just
like with a french fry how you have a
steak fry versus a crinkle cut
versus a shoestring versus a curly
versus a waffle
versus yeah you know uh
a dirty like like a cut like skin on
yeah
all variations of the same thing but
that but each version sort of changes it
up just a little bit
onion rings like any battered food
there's all types
there's the straight up like kind of
italian breadcrumb style onion rings
there's the full on battered ones where
it almost tastes like a funnel cake
or a fried dough on the outside of it my
personal favorite and i don't know what
it's called
are like those ones uh uh
second second picture in from the right
sort of keep scrolling pimp go to the
top again
i think they were at the top oh there
they are homemade onion rings where it
says all the way on the right
up those when it's like that okay i
don't know what that
is dude like i don't know what when
they're like that i'm like
oh yeah here we go um
i i love i love onion rings
they're great i love them they're great
here's where i think
you're gonna find your problems
fries the reason that people like us opt
for an onion ring when the choice is
available
is because of the scarcity of the onion
rings availability
in general terms in relation to the fry
people have been eating fries
by default our entire lives
and so it's a welcome change i think if
you
flipped it i don't know if you'd be able
to eat onion rings
every day like that i think people would
feel differently about onion rings if
they were the automatic side
to every sandwich in a diner every every
triple decker every
every cheeseburger if onion rings i
don't know if we'd feel the same about
them
they it's hard to consume a lot of them
i've done it and uh they're really
really high in
fat and calories but like but if they're
also if they're done a little greasy
like the first couple of bites are great
but then you're really you got a lead
stomach so but you feel you feel you
could eat
french fries every day no because
i mean i might come through another
challenge another challenge of my own
whether i feel like we're trained
because it is the
go-to side or that
they are just a little more palatable
and edible
on a daily basis than any rings i think
is also true i think they're both fried
but like
onion rings have this way of keeping in
the grease and the juice
in between the batter and i mean you
know obviously the best
most perfect one yeah but i'm just
saying i i i don't know man i just like
fries i want to know which
you could you could say you could right
now you could speak for like
five uninterrupted minutes about the
onion ring and i might agree with
everything you say
and then when you're done speaking and
you say now you defend fries
i almost just have to go you know
they're french fries
like they're just like i find it's
french fries i know
who's gonna beat them i find mayweather
i find it's i find that the the
the average i find that on average
the chances of running into an
underwhelming french fry
is far greater than running into an
underwhelming onion ring
well because just for the sheer amount
of fries that are available at all times
well people they might not even have any
rings and they'll have like
at least three fry options awesome oh
you want sweet potato you want curly
sweet potato also we didn't even talk
about it i'll say this too about anyone
i think i take a sweet potato fry over
every other fry
maybe even a sweet potato curly you ever
see them combine those you need to get
out of my face with that
i mean they're they're fine but come on
you'll take a sweet potato fry or a
regular fruit i'll tell you where that's
nuts
crinkle cut fry reminds me of at home
frozen fry
mom making them for dinner you're the
best burnt on the pan that comes out of
the oven
steak cut i relate to a diner
well i guess the curly fry really like
the waffle fry and the curly fried kind
of same but i think the curly fry
is really where it's at the curly fries
i think crinkle cut is your greatest
french fry of all time
because of the crisp they're just so
good dude and del taco's french fries
are crinkle cuts and they're so
good i mean they're insane they're so
good i don't know i think the crinkle
cut unless they're burnt and my
and my mom made them like that out in
the pan
like that or the shoestring
yeah but i'll tell you this um
i think i i and this is another pro for
the onion ring
if you sat me down you said listen dude
we're not gonna be able to eat for hours
you're starving you got to pick
something to eat right now
you get fries or onion rings i take the
onion rings
why i feel like it's a much more
substantial meal
and that's that's even like
nutritionally i feel like you can dip
you're getting onion in it which is nice
and then i feel that you can dip
the onion ring in the types of things
that real foods get dunked into
maybe a ranch dressing a honey mustard
even a barbecue sauce
dare you uh french fries
to me yeah you could say all day you dip
them in mayo and
get out of here you dip them in ketchup
that's what you're dipping i i'll dip a
fry in anything except mayo i don't even
like mayo but whoever wants to dip for
mayo
be you but all those other things you're
like you can dip them in things like
honey mustard probably
of course you can that's done every one
of those things i'm not saying
too i'm not saying you can't i mean you
could dip a hershey bar into those
things too
what i'm saying is the way the flavors
of those dips lend themselves to the
onion ring the way they mesh
the onion ring has an almost chicken
tender flavor to it
and these dipping sauces it allows for a
more substantial robust
uh experience now you love that word
robust but here's the thing
yeah all of those dipping sauces go
as good and complimentary with french
fries so that's a wash
i disagree i guess you're sorry
here it goes you thought it was gonna be
pleasant today
there it is that was where it started i
don't know about how so i i don't
like me because a french fries just a
potato you're just dipping a potato
into that it doesn't have the it's a
golden fried crispy
i i understand just like the underneath
in the same vein as the onion ring
and you could dip it in a mustard
barbecue sweet and sour
as a matter of fact that's what people
dipped them into i'm not saying that you
can't do it
i'm not saying that i don't do it when i
go to mcdonald's
i get a 20-piece mcnugget and i dip the
remainder of my fries into the remainder
of my sauce whatever the sauce may be
yes and it tastes delicious
it's very good but i'll tell you this
had i an onion ring
i'd feel like i was eating more
mcnuggets at that point
i feel like i was extending my meal
significantly so your uh your
one of your arguments for the onion ring
is that it tastes like a chicken nugget
i think it's got a more substantial
flavor to it and a heartiness and a
weight to it that the french fry can't
compare to unless you dump
cheese sauce or gravy and bacon we
didn't even go there
truffle fries parmesan fries disco fries
yeah
we didn't even go there chili fries i'm
not even i don't even really need to go
there
sally boy we both wear glasses yeah
i like a stylish pair of specks then
you're gonna want warby parker i know
stylish specs at an affordable price
that's not even their copy
that's coming from my heart that's
coming from his heart and mine they
provide
exceptional vision care online and in
stores with warby parker
offering eyeglasses sunglasses eye exams
and contact lenses
and these things are starting at 95
bucks a pair and that includes the
prescription lenses you can get your
sunglasses your progressives
the blue light lenses anything you want
it's available you go to their website
you take a quiz
they're going to send you this home try
on kit and you try on some stuff and you
see what you like
yeah they'll send you up to five pairs
and then you just just
you can choose whatever you like you
just see how they look how they fit in
you have to
worry about going to a store i do
remember the first time i started
wearing glasses
when it was years ago and i got my first
pair i didn't realize how expensive
glasses were
like they were like 400 bucks 500 bucks
and i was like wait how am i supposed to
and then you guard that pair of glasses
with your life yeah and then it's like
it's also like the selection wasn't
great but with warby parker when i found
them was like wait a minute
there's like tons of cool styles and
then 95 bucks they started
yeah i was like oh that's when i started
like buying more glasses
i agree going into the to uh going in to
get your new pair of glasses i mean man
you were in there for hours trying
because that's that's the glasses that
were going to be on your face but until
they got lost or broken yeah so it's
nice to have an option where you could
get
if you wanted to three pairs for the
cost of what one pair usually cost
or just get one pair and save yourself
some money try
warby parker's free home try on program
again you're gonna order five pairs of
glasses to try at home for free for five
days there's no obligation to buy
see what looks and feels best okay and
that ships free to you and includes a
prepaid return shipping label
and here's how you do it you go to
warbyparker.com
tastebuds that's
w-a-r-b-y-p-a-r-k-e-r-dot-com
taste buds i like gavin
yeah you like having you know what i
like camping about what
car insurance oh babes and this is for
you tell me about it gabby car insurance
yes when it comes to car and home
insurance don't we deserve better
we do and i know i do i put my policy to
the test and i turn to gabby
and i know you deserve better and that's
why i pushed you to turn to gabby do you
know that it literally stands for get a
better insurance
i didn't i really didn't i'm not doing a
bit for the ad
i didn't know that that's incredible
i love it but who knew something like
this even existed there's
one true comparison platform with real
rates and that's gabby
they're going to give you the apples to
apples comparison of your current
coverage
with 40 of the top insurance providers
like you know progressive nationwide
and travelers all in one place let me
tell you why this is such an important
service to utilize
uh i got a new car recently i hadn't had
a car for the first
year or so that i that i was living back
in new york and when i bought a new car
i had to get insurance
and the dealer that i bought the car
from
gave me all the quotes and the quote
seemed high
to me of course and then i was going and
sniffed around on my own and found out
that i got i was able to get insurance
from one of these reputable companies
that's already been mentioned
uh for about a third of what i was
quoted from the dealership it's huge
i wish at that time i would have known
what gabby was because it would have
saved me a few headaches
but the point is is here they are we're
telling you about them
they're they're helping customers save
961 dollars per year on average and
they're never going to sell your info
you know to spam or robot callers or
anything like that so don't worry about
it you're safe
they're going to help you out this is a
great service
just use it just use it why not it's
just a win-win you're just comparing and
getting the lowest price so it's a tool
that's really gonna help you put your
policy to the test
like joe wishes he did and like we
certainly are gonna do
for the next time we gotta get actually
my mom got a new car yesterday there you
go
just got a new lease and i gotta call up
for insurance for her
i'm going to use gabby her name is gabby
isn't it no oh well that would have been
none of that would have been that would
have really worked
i mean that would have been lights out i
wouldn't think i would have brought that
up sooner get a better insurance with
gabby it's totally free to check and
there's no obligation
go to gabby.com tastebuds that's
g-a-b-i-dot-com
tastebudsgabby.com tastebuds
is because like i feel like i i don't
know i just it'll be a
fries little um right but um what about
a bloom and onion
if you're going there i'm going into
blooming onions i'll give it to you but
i wasn't going to really
i'm also going to go into onion strings
don't open it up i would give it to you
don't open it up no
you don't want me to open it up don't
open it up you know what but your chili
fries
cheese fries chili chili fries truffle
fries that's my
point but that's my point how about my
favorite fry accoutrement
malt vinegar my friend boardwalk fry
malt vinegar my favorite thing to dunk a
fry into
there's nothing that beats it i find it
utterly disgusting boom
chips is an abomination it's like a
heinz malt vinegar like or a classic
you don't love that what do you mean oh
my god we
agree that salt and vinegar chips are
the best chips i love that how different
are you i don't think it's the exact
same food
vinegar on a fry i don't like it's too
it's too robust
but you're saying that salt and vinegar
potato chips
are your favorite chicken hands down
those
and you don't think that a french fry
dipped in mulvaney
i don't know if you've noticed this or
not so with flavors of potato chips
the flavors on the chips don't really
taste like exactly like the thing in
real life
vinegar potatoes i know but it tastes
like it tastes like a light white
vinegar or something it doesn't taste
like
malt vinegar out of the bottle with a fr
it's too much for me punching baby i
love it it's too pungent
but i'm just giving you examples of
fries i want to go back a moment if you
will
the first occurrence of french fries in
america may have been at a diplomatic
dinner
hosted by thomas jefferson they did say
the fry was invented in around 1775
and the onion ring just for facts was
invented in about 1910 1920.
right but if i'm given an option uh
if i'm given an option french fries were
invented by
another one was french fries were
invented by street vendors
on the on a bridge in paris i'm not even
going to attempt that name in 1789
just before the outbreak of the french
revolution however the reference exists
in france from 17
1775 to a few pieces of fried potato
and to fried potatoes okay all right so
so so
so they were made in france but here's
the thing um
if i was someone was telling me you're
gonna have only one you're not gonna eat
until later on you could eat
french fries or onion rings you'll go
back to that it's it's definitely french
fries french fries are
an onion is a vegetable that has no
calorie count
within that vegetable outside of the
fried batter around it all right
but potato is a hearty natural
carbohydrate have you ever heard
somebody say have you ever heard
somebody say i didn't i'm starving i
didn't eat enough onion rings
no you're full you're full after you eat
onion rings i mean i'm just you know
it's like
the hell yeah i love when you do those
quotes you're talking about things like
that
you're talking about it like you're
eating like raw lettuce or something
that's right no but no one's
ever said i'm i'm hungry i didn't eat
enough onion rings no
you said of course i've never heard that
no one's you say the same thing you say
that every time i ate too many onion
rings you feel sick
oh i see what you're saying my point is
yeah but you say the same about fries
it's substantial is my point it's not
empty calories you're eating
to burn off calories in a medium order
of mcdonald's french fries
you would need to do 58 minutes of
cycling
90 minutes of bowling or 45 or 47
minutes of high
impact aerobics i don't believe over
medium fry
i don't know i'll tell you right now i'm
going for 90 minutes of bowling
what [ __ ] wait how are those even equal
you're telling me those are three equal
buckets
47 minutes of high impact aerobics
or another 40 extra minutes of bowling i
don't believe that
that can't be i mean i agree with you on
the bowling thing but
do you agree with that i think these
things are nonsense when they say stuff
like this
well they're giving they're giving an
exact calorie count
to an exact burning of calories so
if a medium fry mcdonald's uses seven
percent of potatoes grown in the united
states for its french fries
they sell more than one-third of all
french fries
sold in restaurants you won't get any
arguments
mcdonald's fries are king but we're not
talking mcdonald's do they have an onion
mcdonald's
no why uh i think
i don't know i was gonna say because
burger king does yeah but that doesn't
matter
it's a burger shop well usually they
steal from one another but they didn't
but did you see the little fact about
burger king
that there's an onion ring in every
order of burger king fries because they
will be because they are letting you
know that they also have onion rings
they do it on purpose
that is genius i never knew that and i
always you always get that loose onion
really yeah
it was on purpose wait is this when is
this
mcdonald's is adding onion rings yes 20
21
is kicking off with a bang with the
announcement that it is finally adding
onion rings to the menu that's right
mcdonald's will be serving
individual onion rings as well as two
new burgers
i mean what are they gonna do with the
end rings because can i be honest with
you
can i be honest with you look how good
those look they look like chicken
nuggets that's what i was saying
they did them different they it's the
chicken nugget batter
they had to do them different than
burger king and what i was gonna say
when i was asking if i could be honest
with you and please let me know if i can
i'm listening i don't think the burger
king uh onion rings are good at all
there's some of my they're very
unfortunate i always get it i always
want them to be good
i pop them in but they're like
forgettable onion rings right
they don't they don't give me the they
don't
get they don't satiate me like when i'm
looking for when i really want an onion
ring
it's not the best it's because it's like
onion meal it's like chopped up onions
not a full piece of onion okay
and that's why they're not great but i
will say this i still get them
a lot of the time of burger king over
the fries i still enjoy them i don't
dislike
i like the taste but yeah they're not
they don't they don't play like the
onion ring
i agree i agree what were the new
burgers mike
eating parsley will help you get rid of
your onion ring breath who knew
who's walking around with onion ring
breath you
oh all right that's stupid what do you
mean who's walking around with on your
ring bro
anyone who eats onion rings onion but
i'm saying onion rings
it's just a weird it's a weird
specificity it's like
i get onion breath but to say like how
do you get rid of
onion rings breath yeah you know it's
weird
outbacks oh
what outback steakhouse is blooming
onion bloom and onion
i just saw the ending it serves six but
it's it's meant for two yeah no that
doesn't serve six
1948 calories
and if that isn't enough outback
steakhouses blooming onion
is 160
grams of fat how many grams how is that
even for your diet
how many grams is that for your day i
think you're supposed to have like
i don't know is it are you supposed to
have like
let's see 2006. 77 grams of fat is in
2000 calories on average
wow so that is two and over two
holy [ __ ] over two times your daily
intake
in one shot
well if you eat a whole blooming onion
by yourself whatever happened
i forgot what happened to what's his
name and super size me no good right
he gained a lot of weight yeah yeah you
mean the [ __ ] that eats mcdonald's
three times a day for 30 days he gets
sick
you know yeah talk to me mr hokey man
yeah well but i mean that's cool for
every day for 365 days i mean if you ate
lettuce three times a day
every day and that's all you ate you
would get sick you know what yeah it was
not like something
yeah it's like it's stupid the highly
adverse effects included severe
headaches
depression severe mood swings 18 pounds
weight gain
chest in one month
and by the way he goes chest
palpitations high cholesterol and
eventually
even liver failure he gained nine and a
half pounds after just
five days of eating super by the way he
he goes
he goes completely batshit every time he
goes
he goes in he gets like the quarter
pound the double quarter pounder
super sized and then nuggets with it
it's like dude you needed to you're
going like
full tilt here it's like nobody's saying
you should go to mcdonald's or
go to fast food if they don't go all the
time they usually
go full tilt but you can't say that's
your rec daily this is my point
it's like who's doing this three times a
day but just think about it every day
think about what you just almost
committed to with the hoagies it's
once a day but for 365 days
but but i mean every day like bastille
yeah
we haven't talked about size yet we have
you know all these things factor into it
okay
but what that guy did was the equivalent
of eating a
15 inch hoagie every day every meal i'm
gonna do
something crazy i'm gonna do something
that i've never done before when we are
done i'm getting fast food today
yeah i can't talk about this but i'm
craving it now yeah
onion rings bad yeah yeah and i'm
defending fries i know i know i kind of
want fries to be honest
let's do a switch real quick first time
ever let me tell you why onion rings are
better
i want french fresh mcdonald's really
bad right now this is it there's a
i wonder we should call right now live
on the air the mcdonald's down the block
and be like you got those onion rings
you know what are they
out yet pimp
let's see right now hold on pimp search
mcdonald's onion ring release date
eat nothing but french fries for 26
years i mean this is what i'm saying
that's 26 years this person did it i you
know
i can't do hoagies for six months how is
it possible
wow that's crazy i've never even heard
of something like this why is she crying
how is it possible though can you just
live off potato
i mean evidently what about all the i
mean
these kids are not fat a teen went
nearly
look at this a teen went nearly blind
due to his love of potato chips and
french fries
jesus a one-sided diet is never healthy
and you can never live off of it for
very long
again that was my whole problem would
supersize me
anything one-sided you're gonna get sick
he could have done that movie about ben
and jerry's
you know what i mean it's like yeah dude
nobody told you to eat it three times a
day there's not there is no food item
that could be used solely without any
other food
items since your body needs all
nutrients let's let's let's see what's
going on here
at the mickey d's i mean if you think
they're answering a phone at mickey d's
you're insane
what's wrong no yeah they have a phone
but what do you think happened it's more
like a suggestion or a decorative item
really yeah decorative yeah do you think
i'm gonna get a recording
i'm i don't even think you're gonna get
that but let's just see what happens
i mean come on guys what are they doing
they're just looking at each other while
the phone rings in there
they're running around like lunatics
making quarter pounders you ever
seen with behind the counter this is not
there's no dining at this one right now
it's nuts behind the counter to mickey d
i mean
no the flow is the flow of the flow of
uh ordering is streamlined because it's
only the drive-through
so i think that i think they're short
staffed i don't even think they have
running running around
this is [ __ ] yeah well
let it be known mcdonald's corporate
they don't answer the phones
it's probably corporate telling them not
to answer the phones
they go do you know what kind of lunatic
would call a mcdonald's
but it's not going to a recording which
makes me feel like
they're just busy and someone will get
to me momentarily
why wh what about no recording makes you
think that
because it's wild to have a mcdonald's a
corporation like that
is are they franchised yes
no like so so yeah yeah so they yeah so
each but each mcdonald's but not every
mcdonald's is franchised by a
individual owner right yeah really
so how much is a mcdonald's i i i i
can't blame them for not picking up the
phone because i just think
who what could anybody be calling to ask
but this is outrageous no
do you is anyone else find this
outrageous no you don't have
like a corporate stock answer machine
like welcome mcdonald's
for corporate press one to hear this
press two for the menu items press
like so so you're telling me that
there's just a bunch of wayward teens in
there
yeah welcome to verizon wireless your
call cannot be completed
it went to verizon wireless that's a
cell phone number you just called
wow wow all right let's go to the polls
pimp
we may or may not be back with french
fries and onion rings yeah french fries
is going to kick your ass back
uh french fries
i love onion rings you never had a shot
today
i don't know i think you're going to be
i think we're going to be
the surprised and the feeling i think
they're going to be so
french foreign i think you're going to
be surprised i think you're going to be
very surprised
that's what i think that's what my gut's
telling me talk to me about ratio
i think it's gonna be close you think
it's gonna be within 10
yeah because i think the passionate
people about uh onion rings are gonna go
hard in the pain here
that's what i think here's where i think
you might have a chance of it being
closer i don't think you have any chance
of winning
is that i think what you said i think
people are gonna be like oh onion rings
if i had to choose i'll choose onion
rings i'm sick of fries
something like that that that kind of
interpretation but we do write which is
better
oh but then again which is better yeah
but fries
fries my assessment is is that this will
be a surprisingly close race
fries are foods at large's best friend
you know what i mean they are the
accompaniment
they are the willing and able
accompaniment
to nearly everything you can have a
steak steak frites babe
you could have a steak with fries you
could have a club sandwich with fries
you could have fries as their own meal
you could have fries the drunk food what
do you think of the fries
how many steaks i've ordered that come
with onion rings on top of them great i
know but i'm just saying you could have
you could have fries at every meal but
onion rings on burgers nobody's putting
fries on the burger
there's places there's no barbecue
burgers they put an onion ring on it
with barbecue i know but there's those
there's those burgers that have
everything on it they they
you could do it but that's not why the
but my my point is the
a fry is the swiss army knife of foods
a fry is the man's best friend
is the canine of foods a fry is the
is the wingman of all foods it is the
most
versatile ready willing and able and
complementary side
to the most dishes possible across the
continents
okay even in other lands fry's reigns
supreme
i just don't see what
looks like sounds very small i need to
go up against a power it sounds
very similar to my snickers bar
arguments
okay and kit kats came in swinging
and i think we're in a similar situation
here i don't know that i'll win
i think it's gonna be a lot closer than
you think i
think let's see what some of the people
i think this is gonna be bad
now stop it so just give your stuff give
me you give me uh
a give me a five percentage
ratio ratio window you think you think
i'm winning i think we're looking at
maybe a 65
uh 35 60 40 maybe even a 55-45
i mean you reduced by you reduced you
went all the way down to five percent
i'm thinking like somewhere in the 1640
area i don't think it's gonna be a
landslide i think it's gonna be closer
than you think
okay okay well i like onion rings and
all you people that like them
good on you for you and i like french
fries and same to you i think we're
going to be more of like an 80 20
scenario here no way
no way let's see i want to see what
somebody i would you know what
we got to do we got to look at what our
our smallest and biggest
win margins were and we wanted to do the
uh we got to talk about the record
yes we'll we'll figure this out we're
going to come back with
who's because i don't know do you know
your record's better than mine yeah i
have no clue no idea maybe we could ask
the fans
no idea we could just look at it yeah
we'll look it up okay here we go
uh a little humble pie segment here we
go here we go we're gonna see where
these things netted out
55.45 i think it's me 80 20 which i
think is the biggest disparity
we've ever had in his terms as guessing
oh wow wow yeah there you have it
decision
holy [ __ ] 17 200 votes
french fries seventy five point three to
onion rings twenty four point seven
and i thought it was gonna be even
higher i thought it was even higher
joe you shouldn't even feel bad you
shouldn't feel disappointed
you know i don't understand
please please speak let it all out let's
just read some comments
i'm at a loss for words right now no are
you
yeah i'd love to know what was gonna
follow i don't understand
i'm at a loss for words okay i'm
literally at a loss for words
at the at the disparity of the loss yes
i can't believe it's that wide a margin
well if you really boil it down and then
the first comment i saw was
french fries dipped in a wendy's frosty
i hate that argument so much
i hate wendy's frosties so much
wow that's crazy you're in the minority
there french fries in the frosty i don't
know why
what it is but people love it but can i
just tell you something all this is is
one in four people prefer an onion ring
i mean if you really want to boil it
down yeah i mean you know 50 50 would be
two and two it's just one in four
who do you think is picking one
that's a great tweet that is great
that's our winner that's that's our
winner that's that's
someone did a poll about who's picking
what and they actually got it right
that is amazing a hundred percent that's
really well it's just she's the only one
who voted on her own poll oh
wow stella was funny i'd rather [ __ ] in
my hand and clap twice and eat hunting
all right retweet that guy too i don't
know it's fair
did she just make it up yeah i think so
i'd rather [ __ ] in my hands and clap
twice than he did that's got to be a
saying follow he's gotta be saying at
quit quite quite frankly frank
or at frankly quite oh is that something
that this thing does
quite frankly i'd rather is that like
the like the whole point of the uh
it's the winning tweet of the ep city
out
[Laughter]
it's poor kid let's read some more folks
will defend and brag on how onion rings
are superior
and also throw away the food tray which
with a whole stack left
okay any rings you're buying ogre and i
know that joe will side with shrek on
this one he's got some weird layers
listen sally i love you but pipe the
down about the onion rings
this is an absolute trouncing for french
fries but william
you didn't even know which one i took uh
if we're all talking if we're talking
all kinds of french fries i assume there
will be an argument but let's just say
we are
waffle fries will destroy any onion ring
that's not true waffle fries are some of
the driest of all fries
uh isabella is choosing who the winning
tweets are now
she's got some real monsters she's the
one that put the poll yeah
all right isabella calm down just
kidding as well thank you
this is wildly disrespectful to french
fries what are you trying to prove with
onion rings you could only fry a
vegetable good for you
wow uh only onion rings i'll eat are
funyuns
you listen to this [ __ ] it's no debate
french fries over earnings no one wants
their bread to smell like it
ate the ass of a skunk uh
i mean don't i haven't found a pro onion
ring yet
french fries are the derosa of the
culinary french fries
this is actually a compound you read it
babe the french fries are the deros of
the culinary world they go well with
everything
the whole world around improve
everything they're added to and make a
delicious meal on their own onion rings
much like volcano or at times delicious
but often
too greasy but a gracie's disappointment
that's great although isn't this person
quite
the egg they have egg on their face
because i took french fries and you took
onion rings i know but it just was a
nice they said nice things about me as a
person
oh i can't wait here you go barry t gave
you some love where
right there french fries people just
might only shovel into their face the
same way you do with chips or popcorn
during a movie the onion ring is for
people who actually want taste what
they're eating
thank you barry like can you go back one
thing
i can't wait i can't wait for joe
derosa to make the argument that onion
ring onion chips
are basically french fries and therefore
onion rings are better because you get
the best of both worlds
yeah he might have went there if we let
him oh boy
all right babe this was a very uh civil
debate today it was it was very you know
part of me just
felt like i i didn't have to do much
heavy lifting with the fry
and so we agree we diverted because
people also like when we start to talk
about other things and stuff
i agree i think it was a fun matchup i
think it was
i think onion rings at 25 is still
admirable
uh i think that french fries has to
fight another day against a powerhouse
give it some real competition all right
maybe there's a maybe there's fair
competition for the onion ring too
that it actually could stand how about
an honey you know would be nice against
the onion ring
the potato skin versus the ending oh we
should have done with onion rings versus
tater tots
that would have been a better but if you
think the tater tot is the best fry
but people at large that might have been
a nice battle yeah more specific
i still think you got potatoes did we
ever do potato skins but they're not a
side dish
yeah you're right they're more of an app
yeah all right all right
well i still love you i love you too
plugs
uh we'll see you in hell available
wherever you get your audio
podcast uh also uh new episodes on the
patreon
patreon.com wsyih podcast
thank you i think tastebuds fans are
coming onto the patreons our numbers
keep going up over there
um the patreon oh to europe the other
patreon yeah yeah so check that out
and that's it for plugs for me i know we
say it but
chris is getting home soon and the no
pressure network will launch
the patreon very soon yeah savile
counter comedy for
any dates that i'm gonna put up uh the
no pressure network
one thing to ask you guys are liking it
um
the only way that the show can grow is
if you spread the word for us so
if you can tell a friend that you think
would like it retweet it rate us
share all that stuff that you always
have people ask it's because it makes a
difference
we're loving doing this you're loving
the show help us out
share it blow it up as much as you can
and we'll keep doing taste buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds